bonjour ils lui sont merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors on
l'a vu un jeu varié delta représente
près de dix pour cent des contaminations
en france
quelles sont les spécificités de ce
variant la spécificité essentielle de ce
variant c'est sa transmissibilité qui
est on l'a dit est nettement supérieure
à celle du variant alpha qui a et qui
était le variant dominant jusqu'à forcer
au cours de ces derniers mois
donc c'est là la règle que nous
connaissons bien maintenant dans ces
épidémies virales
c'est que le le des variants lorsqu'ils
sont mus et dispose de mutation qui les
rendent plus transmissible donc plus
contagieux eh bien ils prennent le
dessus sur le variant précédent il
s'impose donc dans la transmission que
nous observons actuellement en france du
du variant delta il faut l'observer il
faut la surveiller
mais elle ne doit pas être trop peu
inquiétant dans la mesure où nous
opposons toujours des mesures barrières
et surtout dans la mesure où nous
accélérons la campagne nationale de
vaccination puisque c'est sur ce variant
delta reste sensible aux vaccins donc il
n'ya pas lieu de s'inquiéter outre
mesure c'est on n'y plus rien de toute
façon ce variant delta val devenir
dominants ce qu'il faut c'est empêcher
qu'ils suscitent une recrudescence
épidémique comme cela s'est observé en
grande-bretagne et nous connaissons les
moyens il faut maintenir notre vigilance
nous précaution nos gestes barrière le
port du masque en à l'intérieur et
surtout que les personnes qui ne sont
pas vaccinés se fassent vacciner avant
l'été avec les deux doses et ainsi nous
aurons nous pourrons mettre ce variant
sous contrôle sans option difficulté ils
disent on vous parlait à l'instant de
de la vaccination on sait que des quatre
co vides ont été détectés chez des
personnes vaccinées notamment en israël
vous le disent ils
le vaccin est efficace contre ce variant
il empêche ce vaccin une forme grave
du coup vite c'est bien ça tout à fait
ce que l'on observe en israël
effectivement c'est une certaine
recrudescence de la comique 19 juillet à
ce variant delta mais il faut bien noter
que bien qu'israël ait beaucoup vacciner
très bien vaccinés on n'a toujours pas
un niveau de couverture vaccinale de 80
% nécessaires pour avoir l'immunité
collective efficace pour empêcher la
circulation du virus
d'autre part on peut être infecté
lorsqu'on a été bien vaccinés par le
variant de l'état on peut être infecté
mais on observe que ce sont des
infections sans gravité qui n'entraîne
pas de maladies nécessitant
l'hospitalisation encore pire l'entrée
en réanimation est ce que l'arrivée de
ce nouveau variant dans le monde et
notamment en france à travers les landes
on le voit actuellement peu vous ne vous
inquiétez vous professionnels de santé
pour les semaines les mois à venir et
pourquoi pas peut être gâché un petit
peu le milieu la fin de l'été ça peut
effectivement gâcher la fin de l'été si
on ne prend pas les précautions
nécessaires et si on ne se vaccinent pas
suffisamment on arrive maintenant à un
niveau d'épidémie très faible 1 on est
autour de deux mille nouveaux cas par
jour ce qui va nous permettre maintenant
de mettre en place cette fameuse
stratégie est restée isolée tracé isolé
qui n'était pas applicable lorsque
l'épidémie a été beaucoup plus
importante lorsqu'on a vu des niveaux de
d'incidence qui était beaucoup plus
important maintenant on va pouvoir le
faire c'est à dire que il faut qu'on
puisse repérer très très précocement les
nouveaux foyers pour pouvoir isoler
traité est vaccinée
ir vacciner autour de ces nouveaux
foyers pour empêcher leur extension
on a eu donc une arme supérieurs à ce
que nous avions l'an dernier à la même
époque
et là je crois qu'il faut vraiment
maintenir cette vigilance et surtout
développer la réactivité
lorsque un nouveau foyer maire gilles
fau il faut pas attendre il faut que
dans les jours qui viennent on puisse y
reconstruire ce foyer
ça n'a pas été fait dans les landes
puisque le variant d'état a émergé déjà
depuis plusieurs semaines et maintenant
on voit quelle est la situation est
difficile à contrôler il aurait fallu
pouvoir intervenir des premiers cas ont
été dépistés de avec le variant deltort
dans le département des landes et on
n'en serait pas là donc ça doit nous
servir de leçon pour l'attitude à
adopter pendant les modèles alors de
plus en plus de personnes sont vaccinées
en france vous l'avez dit mais beaucoup
d'autres ne le sont pas encore est ce
que vous vous comprenez les réticences
de certains français à vouloir se faire
vacciner
je les comprends pas je ne les comprends
d'autant moins que certains de ces
réticences s'observe même dans le
personnel soignant qui a la
responsabilité de traiter les malades ou
les personnes âgées et vulnérables dans
les ehpad
c'est ces professionnels doivent être
vaccinés
s'il n'en ressort pas l'obligation
morale il faut que ce soit une
obligation réglementaire il faut que une
obligation vaccinale soient rapidement
prises pour tous les soignants et puis
plus largement on a actuellement 30% de
la population française qui a reçu ces
deux infections comme je vous le disais
tout à l'heure
l'objectif à atteindre c'est 80 % oui
bien qu entre 30 et 80 % il ya un
travail considérable à faire et au
rythme auquel nous vaccinons
actuellement nous y arriverons pas si on
compte sur la bonne volonté des gens
pour l'instant les français pensent
plutôt à partir en vacances qu'à aller
se faire vacciner
c'est la raison pour laquelle l'académie
nationale de médecine s'est prononcé en
faveur d'une publication vaccinale à
mettre en place progressivement
tout d'abord à le et du pass vaccinale
c'est pire que de pourront accéder un
certain compte de l'activité de
déplacement de voyage que des personnes
est vaccinée
je crois qu'il faut en venir là si on
veut vraiment atteindre un niveau des
unités collectives suffisant et se
promettre une rampe et ce en
recrudescence
il est mis et son prix n va merci
beaucoup et buissons d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france rappelle
que vous êtes épidémiologistes et
président du groupe kovy 19 à l'académie
nationale de médecine merci beaucoup